non mais c'est vrai en 10 ans de BFM TV
on n'a jamais vu un mec dire ah bah
[ __ ] enfin ça fait trois ans qu'il
égorge des chats dans sa cave et il y
avait beaucoup il y a que vous qui
l'aviez pas vu
et maintenant j'accueille mon stagiaire
Tom villa ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as piqué le sableur de Daniel là
Turner c'est très bien mais non mais on
lui mettra le Gambadou et puis voilà
petit débrief de l'émission de la
semaine dernière sur les réseaux sociaux
les gens trouvent que vous avez encore
fait du Hollande bashing aïe Thierry je
vous avais dit j'y arrive pas on va
écouter je vous ai fait une fiche pour
essayer de dire du bien de François
Hollande merci on va faire un truc
il est gentil et il mange bien la
cantine non non c'est le non non ça
c'est pour mon neveu pardon autant pour
moi
il est gentil
[Applaudissements]
ce soir Thierry Daniel Auteuil Daniel
Lano donc plus grands acteurs en France
alors au début vous avez joué un ado qui
passait le bac dans les sous-doués alors
vous aviez 29 ans et tout le monde a cru
voilà bon en même temps comme j'ai lu
que vous aviez redoublé trois fois votre
quatrième en fait le bac à 29 ans
c'était pas un film c'était un
documentaire
alors on est obligé d'en parler voilà on
vous avait proposé Bienvenue chez les
Ch'tis intouchables et finalement ça
c'est pas fait de film 40 millions de
spectateurs c'est pas grave voilà c'est
pas long mais c'est pas grave il pouvait
pas les faire mais non mais c'est vrai
dû jouer Hugolin et finalement ça c'est
pas cher
Mickey Rourke avait refusé le flic de
Beverly Hills Richard Gere Piège de
Cristal passe partout Game of Thrones
donc ça arrive tout le temps ça c'est
non mais c'est vrai Daniel Auteuil en ce
moment vous mettez en scène et vous
jouez dans la pièce l'envers du décor où
les les pensées secrètes des personnages
doubles les vrais dialogues et ça je
trouve c'est une excellente idée voilà
je vous le disais même si c'est de la
merde je vais pas lui dire
je vraiment j'ai adoré la pièce
je trouve que c'est très bien vu voilà
votre duo avec Valérie Bonneton
fonctionne à merveille
[Applaudissements]
Younes c'est Bambi l'arabe et le Juif
alors juste avant de commencer dites-moi
qui est le Juif qui est le polygame qui
est le lui c'est moi c'est le
coproducteur alors avant le spectacle
s'appelait l'arabe et le juif et vous
avez retiré le titre de la fiche moi
j'ai un nouveau titre à vous proposer mi
cacher mi halal mais 100% circoncis ça
ça peut être c'est très bien ça
[Musique]
Pascal Delatour du pain ah le meilleur
pour la fin la star de BFM TV
le matin c'est William Leymergie et les
Lapins Crétins alors
janvier 2015 BFM TV basse record
d'audience à cause des attentats voilà
BFM TV la chaîne qui va bien quand la
France va mal alors non mais moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup sur BFM TV c'est les
témoignages parce que quand il y a un
drame on chope toujours celui qui est le
plus près de la situation le voisin et
le voisin il a toujours la même phrase
écoutez je suis extrêmement surpris
vraiment je m'y attendais pas du tout
alors pour nous c'était quelqu'un de
sympathie qu'il allait chercher les
gamins à l'école nous disait bonjour le
matin non mais c'est vrai en 10 ans de
BFM TV on n'a jamais vu un mec dire ah
ouais [ __ ] enfin ça fait trois ans
qu'il égorge des chats dans sa cave et
il y avait beaucoup il y a que vous qui
l'aviez pas vu non mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs ici pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
parce qu'elle le Latour du pain alors
vous êtes la seconde matinale de télé de
France juste derrière Télématin c'est
comment d'être derrière William
Leymergie rider non
[Rires]
comment tu vas te sortir de ça
Daniel Auteuil alors Daniel pour votre
dernier mariage vous aviez choisi dev
comme témoin voilà c'est pour l'empêcher
de chanter à la cérémonie
il a chanté on peut pas l'empêcher de
chanter Dave Younes et Bambi dans le
spectacle vous dressez un mur imaginaire
pour pour défendre votre territoire de
scène du coup c'est comment c'est 55 ans
ou c'est comment Palestine 70-30
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu